il avait dans son bon soir vous êtes
président donc des chiennes de garde et
finalement vous vous réagissez assez
assez violemment aux bouquins d'alain
minc et aux propos qu'il tient sur les
féministes quand il dit le film inizmé
la matrice involontaire du
communautarisme déjà vous involontaire
sur dire que les femmes font des choses
sans faire exprès ce qui est pas très
sympa et un peu con pas voilà donc vous
dites les femmes composent la moitié de
toutes les communautés et que finalement
accuser les féministes de la matrice de
communautarisme c'est quelque chose
d'inepte pour vous
oui je trouve que c'est c'est pas très
bien analysé enfin j'étais j'ai été
assez surprise en fait de voter depuis
alors vous avez dit que c'était pas des
épîtres mais j'étais un pitre non j'ai
dit dans l'épître ya pitre c'était dur
est fait avec plus de raffinement et
c'est ce que j'ai trouvé effectivement
que c'était c'est que quand j'ai vu que
vous vous intéressiez au féminisme sur
le moment j'étais contente parce que je
me disais c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose auquel les les élites qui nous
gouvernent et qui nous contrôle ne ne
pense pas très souvent donc j'étais
plutôt content tu es et puis quand j'ai
lu votre votre texte qui fait qu'ils
aient pas très longs en même temps donc
il est assez vite lui eh ben je
m'aperçois que je suis maintenant moi
une maître à penser maîtresse à penser
que je suis devenu de deux mines et je
suis devenue dominante mais pensez si je
suis ravi parce que si moi je suis
dominante est que monsieur minc est
dominée monsieur minc vous êtes un homme
blanc
quinquagénaire
français énarque et je ne crois pas
m'avancer en disant que vous êtes
hétérosexuels donc toutes ces
caractéristiques font de vous exactement
une partie du noyau qui tient absolument
toutes les manettes du pouvoir dans ce
pays et d'ailleurs dans la planète nous
faisait la seule chose c'est que vous
verrez alors qu'elle est donc orientée
maintenant deux mines et moi dominante
mais je vous dis on échange tout de
suite votre position contre la mienne je
prends votre fauteuil au mot et vous
allez retrouver les délices
pari tenu pari tenu le monde contre
ruquier
parle de victoire éclatante de pouvoir
absolu c'est à dire qui dit maintenant
vous avez gagné et tenez nous dans la
compétition mais pas dans la
constitution en gros cela dit ils icône
à gagner et en même temps il dit aussi
dans le même texte que vous faites un
petit peu l'inventaire des inégalités et
des injustices qui subsistent elles sont
nombreuses et variées donc vous dites il
ya encore beaucoup de choses à obtenir
vous dites aussi le féminisme c'était
mieux avant vous êtes un peu le cabrel
du féminisme c'était mieux avant c'est
également un autre quinquagénaire blanc
hétérosexuel et ses
deux millions d'ha énarque
avait tout bon
l'huile est toutes les conneries des
caves et il est pas content c'est ce que
j'essaye de dire c'est que je crois que
l'inégalité est encore très forte pour
nombre de femmes que la manière dont les
féministes mènent leur combat et en
particulier avec ce leurre que la parité
fait qu'elle se préoccupe beaucoup moins
de ses vraies inégalités que d'avoir mis
la parité dans la constitution n'a en
rien fait progresser par les luttes
sociales oui mais bon les lys
chabadabada c'est très sympathique mais
c'est pas le fond du sujet ce n'est en
rien fait progresser l'égalité des cités
dont les rites hector les usines dans
les entreprises de tous ordres dans la
vie réelle et que de ce point de vue
vous trompez de combat je le crois alors
la deuxième chose qui est digne l'une de
nature différente ce qui me choque dans
la parité c'est de dire que les
différences de nature l'homme et la
femme font qu'ils et elles sont plus
importantes que les différences de
culture que nous certaine façon l'ine
est plus important que la qui je pense
profondément que l'idée qu'il y à des
réalités de nature qui demeure et qu'ils
restent prédominantes c'est l'idée la
plus réactionnaire de la terre je crois
que l'égalité et la forme normale de
progressisme mais dire qu'à la fin des
fins une femme sera toujours différent
d'un homme pour des raisons
fondamentales et qu' il faut donc le
marquer dans les textes qui créent cette
différenciation ça me choque
profondément ce que vous dites ainsi
qu'aux états unis par exemple ils sont
capables bayal le système des quotas
mais comme ce n'est pas inscrit dans la
constitution un moment unis
contrairement à ce qu'on croit la cour
suprême a déclaré inconstitutionnels les
quotas or il n'y a pas de quotas
supérieur à la parité alors on que sur
la parité renverser le jeu et par
boutade il vous fait rien à faire si
vous me permettez de vous répondre par
une boutade comme je pense que les
femmes et surtout quand on voit les
jeunes générations qui sortent de
l'université sont en train d'être
meilleur que les hommes on peut penser
que la parité sera le meilleur quotas
pour les hommes parce que nous aurons la
moitié alors nous ne la mérite pas
c'est un usage répétitif du mot marteau
pilon
affirme arriver ben je sais pas j'ai eu
l'impression avec ce livre d'une part
que vous lisiez pas très bien les fiches
qu'on vous donne est donc quelques la
personne qui les a lus pour vous les
apports bien à lui où les a pas bien
compris ce parce que vous vous êtes trop
intelligent pour avoir ses
interprétations là c'est vrai il est
malade mais comme elle est en revanche
je trouve que nous avions une petite
fenêtre ouverte sur votre inconscient
qui moi m'a me confierait marteau pilon
revient trois fois sur 17 pages c'est
beaucoup ce qu'ils allaient voir dans
l'artois chez nous c'est vrai que je
n'ai pas pu m'empêcher d'y voir quelque
chose qui gêne les besoins sexuels
d'ailleurs il ya un acteur de l'année
marteau pilon coût et non mais l'est
elle accepte
le marteau pilon le stade jamais bien
bas la connectique si vous êtes une
espèce de darby je comprends bien oui
oui oui pour ce qui concerne par exemple
la parité là dessus je suis tout à fait
d'accord pardon avec alain minc je pense
pas que elisabeth davin vert oui je
pense pas oui absolument je pense pas
que la vérité soit là je suis absolument
pour l'égalité bien entendu d'ailleurs
il a fait une formidable pirouettes et
buttes à tout à leur expliquant quand
même que la jeune génération des dames
qui sortait de l'université était bien
plus performante que les hommes
également pour donner aux
pauvres mâle dominant comment de faire
rouler
vous aviez totalement raison quand
éclate le coup de tonnerre du deuxième
sexe en effet la condition féminine est
une condition aliénés et il ya une femme
qui sonne pour la première fois la
révolte en 40 ans vous avez gagné ce
combat mais tant mieux il fallait que
vous le gagner mais ne pensez pas que
vous êtes encore dans la position le
prix maintenant je connais tu au milieu
du gué sur la tête ils avaient la chance
non c'est nous qui l'avons fait sur la
tête thierry non mais c'est vrai
faudrait déjà avoir un débat un peu
sérieux rien sur ces sujets là parce que
je sens que déjà on va passer à autre
chose c'est autre chose
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu